Vsauce, Michael here to tell you that episode
3 of Leanback is ready. This week the
topic is temperature from very high
to very low.
It's a television show length
playlist that I host containing videos from
people all over YouTube.
Now, this one's kind of science-y this time, but I think
the videos that make it up are pretty
awesome no matter what.
Now, because I can't send a playlist out to you the way
I can upload a video,
you're going to have to click the first,
top most link in this video's description to
get things rolling.
If you're on a phone,
playlists might not work and if you can't wait
for a better time to lean back,
I've put links to every video in the playlist
down below.
And if you have a site and you wanna embed this entire experience,
guess what? The description has the code you need.
So what are you waiting for?
To get it started and let the videos play
themselves and the Internet do the work,
get some knowledge, click the link...
And as always,
thanks for watching.